[Music]
three years ago this month whitney
houston's only daughter Bobbi Kristina
Brown was laid to rest I sat down with
her father Bobby Brown and he pulled no
punches about the man who was by her
side Nick Gordon does it trouble you
there's a young man walking around oh
it's got three my daughter's gone mad
for him he'll get his God don't like
ugly how much you missing
oh there's no way to explain that
there's no way to express how much I
miss my daughter
Bobby plans to build a shelter for
domestic violence victims in memory of
his daughter
and although gordon has never been
criminally charged he was held legally
accountable for Bobbi Kristina's death
in a civil suit in 2016
now Bobby is opening up about this
painful chapter of his life in a new
biopic of the day that she was buried
how will that time be portrayed I
couldn't be on set at the time because I
just couldn't go through that experience
again the two-part miniseries the Bobby
Brown's story is the R&B singers no
holds bar attempt to set the record
straight on his bad-boy image from his
early rise to fame with the new addition
to the day he first met Whitney at the
1989 Soul Train Awards I'm sorry and
then she did it again she was trying to
get my attention cuz I was fly I knew it
she knew it you know it wasn't what
everybody thinks it was we were a loving
couple we were a loving family
that's the truth about it
[Music]
you see like I said the ups and the
downs you know I'm not sugarcoating
anything and it's moving why do this why
tell your life story in this way there's
so many misconceptions about Who I am as
a man and I think this movie will show
everybody what kind of man that I
actually
[Music]
[Applause]